captured on camera a pivotal moment that
could change the future of the war in
Ukraine president zielinski is told that
after weeks of indecision Germany has
agreed to send leopard two tanks to the
battlefield
leopard two tanks are coming from Europe
you must be relieved
uh
[Music]
um
no
thank you anymore
[Music]
Chancellor Olaf Schultz said Berlin
would send 14 of its tanks and has also
authorized Western allies who hold them
under license to Germany that they can
do the same
there are many citizens in this country
who are concerned also in view of such a
decision and in view of the dimensions
that this weapon entails and therefore I
would like to say to these citizens here
and at this point trust me trust the
federal government
and the birthday gifts just kept on
coming for the Ukrainian leader who is
45 today with the announcement that
after weeks of speculation the United
States is also sending in Firepower from
across the Atlantic in the form of 31
Abrams Tanks couldn't expected Europe
and the United States to weaken our
resolve he expected our support for
Ukraine to crumble with time he was
wrong
so who else has pledged modern military
hardware to Ukraine well the United
States is sending 31 M1 Abrams to
Ukraine though logistics mean it could
take many months for them to get there
Germany has approved the delivery of 14
leopard two tanks Poland has pledged 14
of those German licensed Vehicles the UK
was the first country to promise support
pledging 14 of its Challenger twos
earlier this month
still no committal from France though on
its Leclerc tanks despite promises
earlier this month that they would be
the first to deliver while the
Netherlands Finland and Spain have
announced their willingness to send in
their vehicles
for president zielinski this extra
muscle can't come soon enough it is
NATO Secretary General Jens stoltenberg
acknowledged zelenski's concerns and
said a spring Russian offensive was
highly likely Russia is planning for new
offensives they are building heavily up
they are mobilized hundreds of thousands
of new troops uh ramping or production
acquiring ammunition from authoritarian
regimes like Iran
North Korea and and therefore we have to
be prepared for a new Russian offensives
that's exactly why the announcements
made last week are also important among
with more armor more ammunitions more
also long-range
weapons like the high Mars but also the
new announcements of Battle Tanks so
it's urgent and that's the reason why I
welcome those important announcements
the Kremlin was quick to respond and
said the decision by the West Was An
Extremely Dangerous one and an
escalation of the conflict
today has been a good day for president
zielinski though he acknowledges that
with the first anniversary of the
invasion by Russia less than a month
away darker days do still lie ahead